[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on the other side the notion of pure
insight is something other to itself
than its own object for it is just this
negative determination that constitutes
the object thus from the other side it
also declares the essence of faith to be
something alien to consciousness to be
not its essence but a changeling foisted
on it but here enlightenment is foolish
faith regards that is not knowing what
it is saying and is not understanding
the real facts when it talks about
priestly deception and deluding the
people it talks about this as if by some
hocus-pocus of conjuring priests
consciousness had been palmed off with
something absolutely alien and other to
it in place of its own essence and at
the same time it says that this is an
essence of consciousness that
consciousness believes and it puts its
trust in it and seeks to make it
favorably disposed towards itself that
is consciousness beholds in it it's pure
essence just as much as its own single
and universal individuality and through
this action produces this unity of
itself with its essence thus what it
asserts to be alien to consciousness it
directly declares to be the inmost
nature of consciousness itself how then
can it possibly talk about deception and
illusion since in the same voice it
asserts the very opposite of what it
maintains regarding faith it really
reveals itself to faith as the conscious
lie Howard illusion and deception to
take place where consciousness in its
truth has directly the certainty of
itself where in its object it possesses
its own self since it just as much finds
as produces itself in it
the distinction no longer exists even in
words if the general question has been
propounded whether it is permissible to
delude a people the answer would in in
fact have to be that the question is
pointless because it is impossible to
deceive a people in this manner brassed
instead of
Gold counterfeit instead of genuine
money may well be passed off in isolated
cases many may be persuaded to believe
that a battle lost was a battle one and
other lies about things of sense and
isolated happenings may be made credible
for a time but in the knowledge of that
essential being in which consciousness
has the immediate certainty of itself
the idea of delusion is quite out of the
question
paragraph 550 is a somewhat long one and
it's very dialectical in a sense that
you've got two sides both of whom are in
some sense making demands upon each
other so you could say it's actually not
just dialectical but but a particular
form of the dialectical that includes
something biological where there's a
side that is presenting what's going on
and it's view on everything else and
then the other side that's part of that
picture says well wait a second I don't
think you've got this quite right let's
discuss this or perhaps in a more
hostile way listen buddy you've got it
completely wrong let me tell you how
you've got it wrong and then it's up to
the first side to say well am I getting
it wrong or should I double down and and
and say no no no you're the one who's
wrong this is happening in the course of
enlightenment between pure insight and
faith and when we think about
enlightenment we're normally thinking
about the side that calls itself
enlightened this is one of Hegel's
points that he's making throughout this
section the sign of faith does have its
own counter responses that aren't just
knee-jerk reactions in part because both
pure insight and faith are more than
just superstition or or as he's saying
here something alien something foreign
to consciousness they are consciousness
they are the development of
consciousness faith is not the same
thing as we've talked about before as
the earlier seen unhappy consciousness
or the religion of the family we've got
something a bit more not just
sophisticated but we could say purified
here going on
so Hegel tells us at the beginning of
this the notion of pure insight is
something other to itself than its own
object for it's just this negative
determination that constitutes the
object what is he doing there he's
recapping what has been going on in the
previous discussions saying that pure
insight you know is a negative
determination it's it's you know when it
thinks about its own activity it's
really engaged in negative or critical
orientation
an analysis of whatever it's finding it
doesn't have a content of its own except
that very negativity so he says from the
other side it also declares the essence
of faith the essence than what it is
that is at the very core of faith which
does have content to be something alien
something foreign to consciousness
something that that can't be assimilated
that is in a certain sense if not you
know supra-conscious subconscious below
the realm of the rational below the
realm of what could be explained
this is a typical criticism of
perspectives of faith and you know to be
sure I want to say something here before
we go any further Hegel is not defending
every single religious believer or every
single instance of faith here he's
perfectly willing to say that the the
way in which many people in his own time
and times past and he would say this
about many religious people in the
present the way in which they're
approaching the object of faith or or
the the the content the doctrines or the
rituals is you know very we could say
anti rational right it's not developing
the human being it's telling the human
being to turn their brain off or it up
you know privilege the heart over the
head or whatever whatever else you want
to say that's not a problem because
that's not all that religious faith is
as is evidenced by looking around and
finding people that don't actually fit
the bill for that thoughtful believers
Hegel himself would would place his own
work within that context so he goes on
and he says it declares the essence of
faith of something alien to
consciousness to be not its essence but
a changeling foisted on it some sort of
some sort of you know thing that it's
being asked to take care of a changeling
or you might say a cuckoo
you know the cuckoo bird lays its eggs
and then pushes
you know tries to get rid of the other
birds eggs gets other birds to raise its
own young that's in a sense what what
enlightenment says that is happening
with faith faith is doing this to
consciousness is this really the case is
this this critique on point we could say
Hegel says here enlightenment is
actually foolish now notice right there
this is a very important point
enlightenment is foolish we've got a
contradiction here enlightenment is
supposed to be advanced enlightenment is
supposed to be progressing in terms of
consciousness not regressing into
foolishness so we've got a conflict
brewing within enlightenment itself
notice here here where's faith can
respond faith regards enlightenment not
knowing what it's saying not
understanding the real facts when it
talks about priestly deception and
diluting the people and this is a
caricature right he says it talks about
this as if by some hocus-pocus of
conjuring priest consciousness have been
palmed off with something absolutely
alien and other to it in place of its
own essence so consciousness in the form
of the ordinary person the person of
good sense as we might say has been sold
a bill of goods by these deceptive
priests and it could be you know
Catholic priests it could be you know
Protestant ministers it could be Jewish
rabbis it could be whoever you like
within Western consciousness or you know
it could be all over the world faith can
say you don't actually know what you're
talking about I mean here's one thing
that Hegel doesn't talk about that I
think is really worth remembering when
you're criticizing religious
institutions but you're relying on
stereotypes that may have some substance
at some point in time of your
globalizing from that actual religious
believers can say wow buddy you don't
realize how bad it actually is I mean
you talk
about this sort of stuff happening in
the monasteries but I'm a monk and I can
tell you that that's just you know the
tip of the iceberg as a matter of fact
you don't actually know what the bad
stuff is it's more like the mutual feuds
between us monks or trying to deal with
the fact that this guy gets drunk all
the time or you know on and on and on
and on and we can so there's there's
that aspect you can say wow you know
your criticism it would be on point with
a few individuals but the real problem
is over here that's one thing and that's
coming from experience and presumably
enlightenment would be interested in
actually being as we call it
evidence-based there's a lot of lot of
you might say lip service given to this
that quickly degenerates into an
ideology that just turns against you
know people that belong to a religion or
another religion we can also say that in
a lot of cases the criticisms turn out
to be off-base as a matter of fact
there's an entire literature out there a
fictional literature but based in
people's experiences of like assuming
that this guy is a priest so he's going
to be toeing the party line and he's
gonna be you know telling me this and
this and this and this and when you're
doing that sort of thing you're
stereotyping the other you're telling
them how they're going to be you know
Chesterton's father Browns stories
perfect example of this father brown is
constantly surprising the people who are
like you're supposed to be a parish
priest and you're supposed to think this
this and this and you'll say well yes
but I don't think that and here's by the
way here's the solution to the the
puzzle that you were attempting to find
and here's why you didn't get it because
of your own prejudices so that's what
Hagel is talking about here is
prejudices and that's what enlightenment
is supposed to be attacking getting rid
of right but it's placing that on to the
people of faith so he says going back to
this it's saying that that consciousness
is getting tricked by the priests and
something alien something other to
consciousness is being placed up
of it and it's being told worship this
listen to this shut up don't think just
do what what we tell you to where's the
conflict there he says at the same time
it says that this is an essence of
consciousness so the believer is
conscious the believer is human
consciousness that consciousness
believes and puts its trust and it seeks
to make favorably disposed towards it
that is he says consciousness beholds in
it it's pure essence just as much as its
own single and universal individuality
and through this action produces this
unity of itself with its essence what is
he talking about here the interaction
between the ordinary people the
religious believers and the absolute or
divine the object the individuals and
the essence and the priests are in a
weird kind of state right they're not
the religious object they're actually
somewhat here in the class of the
ordinary people you know they just
happen to be stuck doing the services
and running the show and making sure
that the church doesn't fall down and
all that sort of stuff Wow they've got
these enlightenment Phyllis osore
cultural critics saying oh you're a
bunch of deceivers you know you're just
you're just in it to trick people and
get power right so he goes on and he
says what what what insight is is
declaring to be alien to consciousness
it is directly declaring to be the
inmost nature of consciousness itself so
it's not really alien that was a failure
on the part of insight to be insightful
enough it didn't engage sufficiently
with the realm of faith to know what
faith was actually talking about you
know this is an interesting sidenote
but anybody who says that that you know
Hegel simply attempts to rationalize
faith probably ought to look at this
this portion of the text this is not the
ending of course but you know some of
the polemics that we see
it against Hegel maybe you don't have as
much substance as we might think
polemics from religious people so he
says well then how can enlightenment
talk about deception and delusion in the
same voice that's asserting the very
opposite of what it maintains regarding
faith and that means that it reveals
itself to faith as the conscious lie
enlightenment itself is engaging or
insight itself is engaging in a lie so
Howard illusion and deception to take
place where consciousness in its truth
has directly the certainty of itself now
here he's talking about how can
everybody be in the dark how can
everybody be deceived you can't have it
both ways either people are responding
to the object of faith and orienting
themselves to it because they're finding
something valuable there for themselves
something for consciousness the essence
of consciousness or it's all bs
and these priests have just been
foisting off some stuff on us but then
how did that catch on in the first place
and Hegel says something really
interesting here he says is it pot is it
permissible to deluded people this is a
prized essay right he says the answer
would have to be in fact that this is a
non question this is a pointless
question you can't deceive an entire
people at least not completely right not
in every single respect they are
deceived to some degree he says brass
instead of gold counterfeit instead of
genuine money may be passed off in
isolated cases many may be persuaded to
believe a battle loss is a battle one
other lies about things a sense and
isolated happenings may be made credible
for a time but in the knowledge of the
essential being in which consciousness
has the immediate certainty of itself
the idea of delusion he says is quite
out of the question this is a bit a bit
of a challenge here isn't it because
when you read that you're like well you
know what about the development of the
history of religions right don't we say
that maybe people were deluded at one
point I got a better idea is this
compatible with what Hegel's talking
about aren't there are plenty of
religious people who are confused even
about what their religion is teaching
aren't there many priests ministers you
know whoever else we want to talk about
who who get confused who are deluded who
do in fact engage in deception and Hagel
consents yes that that's true isolated
cases however not simply the norm across
the board as enlightenment represented
in pure insight is claiming to be the
case
let us see further how faith experiences
the Enlightenment in the different
moments of its own consciousness to
which the view mentioned above referred
to only generally these moments are pure
thought or as object absolute being in
and for itself then its relation as a
knowing to absolute being the ground of
its belief and lastly its relation to
absolute being in its acts or its
worship and service just as pure insight
has failed to recognize itself and has
denied itself in belief generally so -
in these moments it will behave in an
equally perverse manner
paragraph 551 is very short and I think
the way it's it's framed it could be a
little bit obscure to the reader as to
what exactly Hagel is is talking about I
think that this this notion of you know
three main moments of consciousness that
that we've already talked about quite a
bit and I think that'll be familiar to
those who have already gone through the
paragraphs in this section remember that
both faith and insight have these these
three moments but you notice now at this
point one of the moments before had been
its relation to its other meaning it you
know faith in relation insight insight
in relation to faith and now we've got
something different as the third moment
here so it looks when we give it a first
read he says let us see how faith
experiences the Enlightenment in the
different moments of its own
consciousness to which the view
mentioned above or refer to only general
right and they says we've got these
three moments so these are the ways that
faith itself is making sense of its
experience but how are these experiences
of the Enlightenment so we got to dig a
little bit deeper in order to talk about
this these are the things that insight
is going to be looking at and saying
well this is what it is for faith and I
in sight understand that better than
faith does in this way so insight is
going to be looking at pure thought or
absolute being in and for itself as it
is for faith insight is going to be
looking at faiths relation of knowing to
absolute being and saying well you don't
really have any knowledge at all insight
is going to be looking at the relation
of acts of worship and service to
absolute being and also saying these are
blasphemous these are sacrilegious these
are you know superstitious these are
these are not good
that's what Hegel is actually talking
about here so he tells us what what
these three are right pure thought
relation is knowing and relation to
absolute being an act and he says just
as pure insight failed to recognize
itself and it denied itself and belief
generally so - in these moments it will
behave in an equally perverse manner now
what the question there is well what is
this it are we talking about pure
insight behaving in a perverse manner or
are we talking about the thing that we
began this paragraph with talking about
faith is faith behaving in an equally
perverse manner so that there's kind of
a mirroring of what's going on with
insight the answer is this insight is
depicting to itself faith as acting in
an equally perverse manner and that is
how insight is actually getting faith
wrong so this is a very important
realization when we think about where
we're going in the next paragraph
pure insight adopts a negative attitude
to the absolute being of the believing
consciousness this being is pure thought
and pure thought posited within itself
is an object or as an essence and in the
believing consciousness this intrinsic
being of thought acquires at the same
time for consciousness that is for
itself the form but only the empty form
of objectivity it has the character of
something presented to consciousness to
peer in sight however since it is pure
consciousness from the side of the self
that is for itself the other appears as
something negative of self consciousness
this could still be taken either as the
pure intrinsic being of thought or also
as the being of sense certainty but
since it is at the same time for the
self and the self qua self that has an
object is an actual consciousness the
object proper is such is for pure
insight and ordinary thing of sense
certainty that merely is this it's
object is manifest to it in the picture
thought of faith it condemns this
picture thought and in its own object
but in apprehending the object of faith
as incites own object it already does
faith or wrong for it is saying that the
absolute being of faith is a piece of
stone a block of wood which has eyes and
sees not or again a piece of dough which
have having come from the field is
transformed by man and returned into
Earth again or in whatever other ways
faith anthropomorphize --is absolute
being making it into an object that it
can represent to itself
in paragraph 552 where we're looking at
one of the main ways in which pure
insight manages in its critical analysis
of faith to mistake what faith is
actually up to to get faith wrong and
thereby to attribute to faith a sort of
consciousness and naive consciousness
that it doesn't really have which means
that in a certain sense pure insight
itself shows itself as being more naive
than the naive consciousness that it is
criticizing and it's going to as Hegel
says adopt a negative attitude or negate
the absolute being of faith saying that
this cannot possibly be the absolute
being for consciousness faith is getting
this wrong so this is that that first
moment of you know what we were talking
about in the previous paragraph right
the moments of faith as consciousness
pure thought or as object absolute being
as it is in it for itself so what is the
being for faith well faith is a mode of
thinking so as Hegel says this being is
absolute being is in fact pure thought
pure thought posited within itself as an
object or in as an essence in the
believing consciousness this intrinsic
being this is this being in itself on
Zeke of thought acquires at the same
time for consciousness that is for
itself the form but only the empty form
of objectivity as the character of
something presented to consciousness and
so there is a kind of alienation going
on here that we've already seen right
that's that's not being debated her it
there is in fact an alienation of
consciousness where pure consciousness
the individual consciousness and the
question is what does this correspond to
is this just an ideal that has no
reality whatsoever projected out there
into a kind of void well if it is then
enlightenment and pure insight is
actually getting faith wrong
focusing on the picture thinking aspect
of it so let's let's turn to that so he
says to pure insight because pure
insight is pure consciousness from the
side of the self that is for itself that
understands itself that that attempts to
take a critical attitude on itself and
on the rest of the world and on other
consciousness the other appears is
something negative of self consciousness
so you know you get attitudes of well if
that's what you mean by God then God
ends up negating the rest of us so we
must negate God and you could think of
you know writers like for example
jean-paul Sartre in the 20th century who
say things like this or much more crude
you know atheist Crusaders let's call
them who similarly misrepresent what it
is that religious believers actually do
in fact think or at least some religious
believers the ones who are more rational
and less superstitious so he says what
could this is this negative of self
consciousness be says this could be
taken as the pure intrinsic being a
thought or as the being of sense
certainty and now we have an interesting
transition you remember the sense
certainty was the realm of the senses
right it's where we began the entire
phenomenology after we got through the
introduction and the before that the
preface
so Hegel here is talking about the
crudest form of self-consciousness the
aura of consciousness we're not even at
self-consciousness at that part of the
work right and he's saying that this is
what enlightenment thinks that the
religious believer is doing and if you
think about you know some of the works
that are out there like just read Humes
natural history of religion or Hobbes's
remarks on religion and Leviathan you'll
you'll see where this comes from some of
Rousseau's ideas as well so he says
we're going and looking at at you know
sense certainty and then he says
sensitives at the same time for the self
and the self as self has that
an object is an actual consciousness the
object proper is such for pure insight
becomes an ordinary thing of sense
certainty so when pure insight looks at
religious believers at religious
comportment at religious rituals at
institutions what it sees are the things
a sense certainty it doesn't see them as
the religious believer sees them because
it doesn't think there's really anything
there beyond that this stuff up here
absolute being for the religious
believer to be seeing in those physical
manifestations in those sensuous let's
call them images here Hegel's talking my
picture thinking but we could just as
well say images right why is is it pure
insight wrong about this well when you
actually do go and talk to religious
believers about the physical apparatus
of their place of worship or you know
there are texts or the rituals that
they're engaging in or other things they
will say that those those things of the
world do in fact matter but does the
religious believer in the temple really
believe that the God just is the statue
I mean some religious believers do but
most say no no the statue is a symbol of
something you know we don't actually
worship the statue we're worshipping
that which the statue represents or even
not even worshiping it but venerating it
saying this is part of a religious
community there's there's a lot of
different wrinkles involved here right
when you're consuming this or that you
know in a religious ritual are you
actually consuming the God him or
herself or is there something else going
on there so Hegel says that going back
to pure insight the object for it is
such is an ordinary thing of sin
certainty that merely is just as being
this its object as manaphy
to it in the picture thought of faith it
says listen you faith people you're kind
of dumb you're you're relying on
pictures rather than concepts you're
what you what it is that you're using to
to conceptualize at it's a
conceptualized absolute being is not
really a conceptualization it's merely
making some nice pictures or images or
however you want to frame it so if that
were in fact the case
pure insight would be right in as Hegel
says condemning this picture thinking
now notice what he says here then
apprehending the object of faith is
incites own object it already does faith
or wrong and this is important because
pure insight is supposed to be getting
things right that's what allows it to
take it's critical attitude so if it's
critical attitude is another way of
getting things wrong we're posed here
with a real problem maybe nobody's
getting things right that would be a
real kick in the pants for pure insight
not so much for faith faith has an
object pure insight needs an object and
it needs to get that object right so how
does it do faith or wrong Hegel says it
is saying that the absolute being of
faith not absolute being as such but the
absolute being for faith is a piece of
stone a block of wood which has eyes and
sees not or again a piece of dough which
having come from the field is
transformed by man and returned by earth
again or look at how Hegel leaves us
open in whatever other ways faith
anthropomorphize is absolute being
making it to an object that it can
represent to itself so any religious
objects any religious sensuous things
are inadequate to represent absolute
being but faith doesn't say that they
actually do adequately represent
absolute being and it's a miss
attribution on the part of insight to
say that faith does now can you find
some people who are within religious
communities or our religious believers
who do say boneheaded things not
actually understanding there very often
their own religious communities
teachings on these matters oh absolutely
all right so we do find cases where a
per
you know looks at an icon and thinks
that that icon is is itself Jesus or go
on and on with with other examples but
but that's not the totality of faith
certainly not faith in the Enlightenment
when faith is itself under a microscope
and being critiqued so this is a very
important getting things wrong
notice what Hegel is doing here this is
the last thing I'll say he is engaging
in critique of those engaging in
critique is he doing so to take the side
of faith he is not he's casting himself
as being somewhat outside of the
conflict and looking in on both sides of
the conflict and finding out where
they're off-base
you